hello and welcome everyone to another
episode of rent cafe Ranke faith 43 I'm
your boy adam ak for anime uproar and we
do this every week
Thursdays 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
just chatting about anime with some cool
people the coolest of which is me
however all the other guys are pretty
cool too joining me today
by the way today we'll be talking about
the fall 2017 anime seasons season what
looks good what looks terrible what
recon will be watching though this is an
important one and soul I'm sold with me
today we got the crew we got soul maka
Luo artists and jack-of-all-trades in
general
what's up soul yeah man I'm good I'm
good
how's everyone of them enjoyed oh good
man good to see you all ah we also got
anime recon the top who's the main
character the top 10 list crusher and
harem edgy anime lover what's up ice
cream XQ am yes as muck said I'm an
expert
yes thank you thank you so much
hopefully you all know I win the top
tens even though I do most of your top
tens
you're still the expert no you don't do
most of my top tens lately and fine
thank you and finally we also have the
sarcastic the belligerent did sometimes
downright cynical knocks yes it's not
who hello uh thank you very much for
having me actually I wanted to say
congratulations because I wasn't on the
50,000 subscriber livestream so I wanted
to take this moment to congratulate you
formally on 50,000 subscribers and that
I intend to make a video congratulating
you on its own
what whoa hello okay and I brought a
friend
hey what's up no you didn't
Auggie dearest hey what's up good hi Aki
I'm a I'm I'm gonna fangirl right now
right now like super fanservice is like
coming through yeah yeah we were saying
that this is a sausage fest of waka Maki
it's an honour
yeah no worries yeah it's nice to be
here nice to finally like meet you we've
been like hitting each other in the DMS
every now and then so it's like ah now's
the time yes we voice Jonny that's very
cool yeah well you know if I actually
just uh was just reading your message
now I thought you sent me and I can just
talk to you later if you want yeah yeah
for sure yeah Luke Bryan Lawrence oh
yeah nice to meet you dude he was
selling me a nook stock it was telling
me about like the idea so I was like
yeah let's do it
awesome awesome well thank you so much
for taking the time machi this is a
total surprise by the way everyone not
you
because Knox was like regal cryptic he
was being all cryptic and I was like
okay okay whatever and then this happens
so yeah yeah yeah no it's it's fine like
here actually oh wait connections kind
of weird is it good thank you yeah you
brought up the idea with me and then I
was just like dude that sounds actually
really awesome I need to meet the guy
anyway so why not
it's a pleasure I like you because I'm
like I've been watching you for 42 years
something like that so yeah yeah
definitely
dude it's so like cool seeing you like
how you grew cuz I've been watching your
stuff as well like every now and then
and I was like dude at least like you
know you can articulate a stuff well and
then make the way that he's just
expressing the news and everything and
then I saw like your attack on Titan
when I was like yeah this guy's pretty
good and then you started glowing up I'm
like finally he's getting some
recognition so oh thank you so much and
yeah like I know you've been supporting
the channel and everything and I really
appreciate that and at first
I love everything that you and Joey have
done and how you guys have been pillars
of the community and doing charity work
now and everything it's
yeah definitely we definitely like to
just uh be part of the Anna Tube
community so I'm happy to say that we've
become a part of it and that we've been
able to meet a lot of different people
such as yourself
so yeah been a pleasure and I think this
community is really cool very I didn't
know like ass cuz we're pretty recent in
this and we've managed to kind of meet
people and some really cool people as
well and the fact that like bigger
youtubers such as yourself and Joey and
Misty actually care about the community
and smaller youtubers and take the time
to check them out is I think rares
so yeah thanks yeah no worries I mean
the attitude community is quite I guess
like smaller a and sort of niche on
YouTube as it is so there's not really a
point in like separating everyone in in
our opinion that's kind of what we've
always done and so who's funny at Anime
Expo and a lot of us met such as like
other ones like getting a super eyepatch
wolf and like with hawks anime like we
all just kind of called it a world
conference so we've had this like
ongoing thing where it's like we kind of
want to just get everyone together it's
kind of I think it's kind of time that
we've done this but yeah so let's go you
want to talk to about so like anime and
stuff bro I guess I guess we could do
that but yeah that's definitely cool
plan I'm down I'm down to help anytime
but yeah so today what we will be
talking about before I was thrown for a
loop is fall anime season what we're
looking forward to and personally I have
very little idea of what's even coming
up so I'm kind of a total virgin for
[ __ ] 17 animes so if anyone knows and
wants to start kind of like what you're
looking forward to I will open the floor
up well I mean I'm just looking at the
list right now
so I mean I think we're all on the same
boat it seems like there's a lot of oh
god we're getting another game of
umaru-chan I did not know that
yes season 2 I haven't seen the first
season I'll be honest you know what I'm
actually making a slice-of-life
video right now it's gonna be like a
video essay which I haven't done in a
long time and I kind of throw a little
bit of shade
what I didn't like about him all through
umaru-chan just because I think she was
really popular but the problem I have
with her is she seems to be pretty much
in extraordinarily different character
while and pretty much the center of
everyone else's lives I tend to like
slice-of-life anime where everyone kind
of plays a different part in different
personalities that kind of bounce off
one another but this is more so like
very heavily on her which her
personality itself I was never really
fond of in the first place
yeah like I I don't know anything but
yeah I mean I like I know the set up but
I know that everyone on our discord
server who uses anything from Maru like
whether the profile pictures or the
names
tends to be a crazy character quite an
interesting character so that is
something John is an annoying little
[ __ ] pretty much I was trying to be
like totally pro with it but trying to
be on being all nice about it wow she's
a character that sometimes no she's not
she's horrible oh yeah I mean she's just
extremely hyperactive which you know I I
mean I've seen those before but I feel
like you know I don't really I've kind
of grown outgrown that kind of character
I suppose and the way that she's
portrayed I guess I just don't like it
that's the thing about slice-of-life is
like it's so heavily character driven
that if it's really personal preference
that if you don't like the characters
and you don't really find any point in
wanting to follow their lives or who
they are in the first place at least
about Amira Chen something that annoyed
me personally I know a lot of people
like this is that she had a totally
normal persona you know outside in front
of people and then she goes home and she
becomes a greedy [ __ ] and her brother
is like in hell and I have a little
brother who luckily treats me and of
like that sometimes and I know that
feeling of that poor brother yeah I know
the feeling of someone acting normal
outside in front of others and then
inside just being a little demon mm-hmm
yeah yeah I think I think the people
that like it just are very appealed to
just
I don't want I'm not gonna call her muy
more just like oh it's so cute look at
this girl being so hyperactive and she's
playing video games I play video games
too but I think for a lot of us as well
it kind of divided a lot of people of
what we could tolerate I'm strict on a
PewDiePie his favorite anime I know
personally I also have a little brother
and heels
he runs the channel with me but mostly
he lately has been just doing it helping
me with the editing but yeah definitely
little brothers are yong-go aquila
sister but the younger siblings they're
so privileged man you know always favor
them and they pretend like they don't
see it they pretend like they don't see
it it's like no it's totally fair like
oh and my parents like you should know
better you should know that and then
he'll do song as well y'all he's still
young he's the he's a he's an adult
[Music]
well my brother doesn't help me with
editing he's a master of critique though
I'll say well I don't know why you made
a video on this oh there's a third
season of food Wars you know what I
actually haven't even started the second
one yet you know there is some food wars
but we have some people in the shop
Philly Superman cat gamers saying hey
we're younger siblings well I'm
disappointed to hear that I just planned
but you know mmm things well from
watching food Wars I did enjoy the first
season but the second season it was mad
just because mostly just focused on the
tournament arc it was really my thing
but I'm looking forward to the third one
you know a little bit more better
expectations for that hopefully it's not
too much a little on the [ __ ]
tournament arc I definitely just like
health food wars won I mean I think it
just makes everyone hungry but like how
serious they make culinary to be it's
kind of like it's kind of like watching
a very intense sports and like a GUI
with food basic reapmon did I just hear
you say you did not like an edgy
me what recon you you said you didn't
like the second season it's itchy I know
I know but it just it wasn't enough it
was so focused on the tournament arc
like I said too much tournament too
little itchy
exactly yeah by the way Aki recon is our
resident guy who loves G harems not
ironically also Sao nan ironically he
thought were like the first half hour
that recon was just playing a character
but he was just being Langley messing
around and we're like no misty he really
feels this way so hum recon is like a
huge addition to the team here because
he's such like a counter-argument in
person door that's Miyake nice to meet
you yeah basically I am the I'm the
Joker it Len I'm the Joker in this clan
so um you know yeah favorite horror on
what would you say the XD okay yeah no
yeah no argument about that mm-hmm can
we all except recon agree that Keijo is
far superior to the XD No thank you I
can agree to that
no no oh are you still with us
yeah I'm still with you but you know
just letting people say their piece and
stuff
nice you Keijo better then I still need
to watch K Joe but I know I dropped
because the XD was just crap it was just
yeah it's just the light that's all is
is the purpose the light and I was just
like no so not for me first of all I
just
by the way soul is a hentai artist Aki
oh that's pretty awesome
yeah he's the hentai artists and he just
said that he didn't like pervs the light
passing it to actually get it the light
in there you pay me to watch it then you
know I'll watch it that's something I'd
say probably my favorite is mmm I don't
know I mean I really like monster Musume
but I think just harem in general
probably still shuffle shuffle I like
Tina as well but talk about their shake
lucky no was the first harem I ever
watched for me shokugeki is bit of a
one-trick pony
there ain't really much else to it so
I've got kind of bored with it kind of
quick hmm much else going on and um oh I
did enjoy I find the cue eccentric
nature of a funny so I did enjoy that
okay a series that I know lots of people
liked but I just didn't like was kono
Suba know some reason lots of people
like it I don't know why yes supa is
hilarious
for what it is same thing with cage oh
it's like a show that knows what it is
it has fun with it it's not it doesn't
take itself too seriously which I
respect so that's why I enjoyed both
kono Suba and kate Roble you have to
suspend disbelief
you came to an expecting like a you know
like a masterpiece Oh
parent k jo to kono Suba because while I
think Kona su while K Jo's a great show
in its own way just because the plot is
so over-the-top I think the reason why
Kona Suba is so great is because the
cast is so over-the-top hmm dark this
best girl I don't care what anyone says
Megumi and best girl bro watch that cake
I Simpson do they know all of stuff yes
I watched the preseason a kekkai sensen
no yes what did you think of it great
ending theme song yeah what about the
show general so much I have to say the
characters were a bit flat and there was
no really progressive storyline I mean
they tried to make believe there was but
there really wasn't not a feel about
eunuchs but the show is actually number
one popular in fall enemy 2017 it's
actually not I don't know what list
you're on but shokugeki it is I'm on any
chart right now on
it's not is not the it no one goes by
that aside from you I love you guys I
love both of you like oh damn it usually
have we just never agree on anything
Knox just go to my anime list okay calm
down everyone
black clover no no don't it don't want
to line life saying black clover
something we're saying is gonna be the
next Naruto other people are pissed off
because people are saying is gonna be
the next Naruto so I'm seeing a lot of
mixed reactions to this anime I talked
about it a bit before in one of the news
vids but basically it's kind of like a
mix of all these popular anime tropes so
we have a guy who is born without
magical powers in a magical world so
kind of being queer class in my dear
academia then we have him trying to be
the wizard King like Pirate King in one
piece
so what do you guys think I would read
the manga but do you think this can beat
me you know live up to the hype or do
you think it's just to kind of trying to
be what something it's not I read the
manga okay with the manga to test it out
to see what it's like to you know try
and gauge the complaints and see if
they're valid or not and the feel of
show is the same as fairy tale but then
the character in it the main characters
like story and stuff is like basically
Naruto so we've got we've got the case
of him being like without magic which
you could say is the king - nuru or not
being able to you to chakra properly
because the other demon Fox in them and
then the boys tall or way to overcome
magic is then this demon book which then
you can then say oh he got the demon Fox
yeah I mean and there's a lot of things
that go on and you can see certain
characters like they've got a character
like Connor from very tall who always
used to kind of like drink and stuff but
she's mixed with great because she likes
the strip so she's always drinking I was
wondering when they were gonna get a
girl with that issue yes it's yeah you
can see a lot of different like tropes
they all
tis like gettin rehashed within the
story and then wells right the reason
why I'm looking forward to black clover
well there's two reasons mainly why I'm
looking forward to it there are a bunch
of negatives I see a lot of cliche I see
a lot of you know redundancy and it's
done by Piero which is not good in my
opinion but the two things I am looking
forward to is I since I did not read the
manga I don't know but in all the anime
you've mentioned there were never two
protagonists that were allies and rivals
that just went through it gray and Natsu
you know they met up for bits and pieces
but for the most part they were sort of
doing their own thing and hated each
other when they met these two seem like
friends which is I don't know it could
be a much more interesting dynamic and
the second reason why I'm looking
forward to it is because I am working
with someone on a bridging it so that
will be awesome I just want to point out
really quickly that I'm a little bit
disappointed for next season one can I
guess is because know there is a cheat
but there is not a single harem anime
coming out next season which is
disappointing
there is edgy which Elmo which I'm you
know I'm happy about but there is not a
single harem anime anime did any of you
notice boku no kanojo got whatever
thingy
show [ __ ] the most screwed up anime
thing I've ever heard in my life
picture is and I was pretty surprised
about what I've seen so I'm excited for
that show is that a banana in the
pollster like a banana from a POV
perspective with all these chicks I mean
it's just like a cool girl just think
about it as like a whole girl if you
guys have watched it this is mine this
is my reaction to this post it's almost
similar like ah whoo girl the banana
girl
well like Jonathan Essex comment in the
chat he said that black clover is shown
in the anime so just like the
generic all the tropes let's just throw
it in there see what happens I will see
well by that effect my hero academia is
also shown in the anime True Blood and a
lot of people seem alike that is a cool
character so but who's a cool character
hold it okay okay I agree with you
that's one cool character deck who's not
particularly cool yeah I agree but you
know maybe okey so since we know you
have millions if not billions of fans
around the world billions if not Billy
what are you seeing some hype for any
particular anime for this coming season
from you know people in the comments on
Twitter oh when you say this isn't the
fallen or right now yeah are you seeing
Ock you make a video about this so we
want to you we want to see what you
think about that yeah the one that I'm
actually looking forward to in fall is
the third season of March comes in like
a lion I was a huge fan of that series I
remember correctly on the Lightning
ground you said that was one of your
favorite somethings yeah it was um it's
it's a slice of life but like it's a
saint and drama so it's not really about
like following this guy in his
day-to-day life it's kind of just
figuring out what the heck happened to
him and what's making him so depressed
so but yeah I know I would I said that
it was one of the first anime in a very
long time I actually cried it and yeah
it's because it's just kind of about
this kid who he's like a 30 year old in
a 17 year old body where he's kind of
pressured to be this successful shogi
player and he kind of just lives life
alone and he has nothing else to live
for but this one particular game that
he's really good at and he has nothing
else in his life and he so he has to win
in order to make a living and also it'll
be the last thing that he'll lose in
life but you see it kind of like the
burden of what it's like to be a winner
when you see
what happens to the loser so like if he
goes into a competition and he goes up
against someone he says that like he
could easily lose and at least give this
person a chance but he doesn't want to
and so when he wins the loser just kind
of like leaves disappointed and he knows
exactly what he did to this person so
it's like a it's basically one big teary
eye like emotional right and I think the
other one I'm interested in is just
because yes I was just gonna talk about
that yeah I it just looks really
interesting at the end of the second
semester of third year of high school
for students are prepared for graduation
and feel the ending of their high school
life yeah I feel like a lot of people
can probably relate to this song it's
relatable but it's also an original
series and I've yet to be a good one
well this was gonna be my romance of the
season definitely yeah oh is this a
romance yeah it's just romance it's
gonna be romantic without me although
you never know man because it remembers
Kurt Nonaka yes you were doing the same
thing for the previous season we were
like oh so this is gonna be URI skirt
nanaka stuff happened definitely happen
I'm pretty sure it's solo should be
watching this we say watching watching
you're still watching it recon
no I said I'm pretty sure soul is still
watching it I mean should you go arching
it yeah no sky no naka no no no no no I
you know drawing ideas no no no once
there and I won I won't prepared for it
it's like it's like finding a a key
surah on anime site and you expecting it
to be anime and then gets to those
certain scenes and then you're like wait
hang up wait what is this like just
saying anime yeah he's pretty much like
that
haha I want actually still watching
Nestle trap if you believe it or not
and water what nets or trap ntr yeah the
the two girls that yeah like each other
even thought about boyfriends so yes a
mess I like I like the free cats you
know lion first season it followed the
manga well I the second season I think
will be more interesting and I wouldn't
say that Ray is completely on his own
because he does have those like three
sisters that are kind of like an
adoptive family to him kind of yeah
they're kind of there's kind of
symbolizing his escape or they're kind
of like his salvation to help him solely
to get over like whatever troubles he's
going through yeah I I actually I
dropped the first season somewhere in
the middle I think around episode seven
ish okay I couldn't connect to the guy
it's definitely also a lot of freaking
dialog it's just the depressing and also
art style is a little off-putting I mean
not not that it's enough to make me drop
the show but it was definitely an added
feature that I didn't particularly enjoy
I like the art style and reminded me of
was there were too many frowning people
it was like a whole show about frowning
people just I'm just pretty much
surprised no one mentioned mapa the next
anime you know you shocky yeah it's
based off a manga that's actually
supposed to be pretty good I mean the
watch the trailer it looks dope with the
old man in the cover as well well yeah
the six it's about a 60 year old dude no
yeah yeah the things that caught my eye
then I'm a little bit excited for is
show Joshua Matsu ryuko you know I was
just gonna say that one because that one
looks actually pretty sick yeah it's an
adventure slice of life and it's made by
white fox which impressed me with
everything they make almost except for a
comic a kill and it's setting like seems
interesting it starts off describing
it's civilization is dead
like okay this is gonna be decent it's
bull like slice-of-life there can be
some really good ones I love June Maya
double though I think 50% of it is the
music like I don't like they could be
probably saying the stupidest [ __ ] and I
would just be listen to music oh my god
so beautiful
but like slice-of-life are kind of
playing it safe because there's so many
in the genre it's a you know setting
that everyone can relate to when you do
like a post-apocalyptic anime it's a
more like a sci-fi or whatever it's a
more bold choice so it's more risky so I
definitely do appreciate those speaking
of which has anyone watched quino's
journey the original no nope it's like a
short anime like 10 or 11 episodes it is
based on a manga and read the manga but
now they're they're doing it like a redo
of it it's coming out in October it's
called Tina no Tommy or quino's journey
the beautiful world and I actually
really loved the original like it's a
weird series it's like about this young
girl kind of like cute all that kind of
stuff and she's journeying through this
fantasy world and every episode is like
teaches about human nature and there's a
lot of cruel crazy stuff happening like
you know groups of stuff like
cannibalism stuff like that
and on top of that it's there's a lot of
like a beautiful aesthetic of nature and
kind of like teaching life lessons so
it's a very unique interesting type of
anime I definitely am looking forward to
seeing this remake I don't know if it's
gonna be as good as the original but if
you guys haven't heard of that one it's
definitely a sleeper potential good
enemy yeah I was actually looking
forward to that as well Aki don't you
need to go oh by the way yeah so but
it's actually extended up to 3:00 p.m.
so you're gonna get out of here in like
8 almost 10 minutes yeah whenever you're
gonna leave I'm just surprised you're
here and really are you gonna leave we
know you're busy but really appreciate
this oh yeah I'm sure you're always
invited back yes open invite opening
knocks your invite is a bit more rigid
but for Aki open annoyed
I could deal with that yeah your your
mind it's more conditioner a few people
that I would accept being on the lower
rung of the ladder no I you your you
your we've ten we're we've ten we are
we've ten so it's not really looking
forward to next season that you haven't
mentioned yet in fact I'm really looking
forward to it is Gintama but I don't
know if any of you watch it nope I don't
I think it's hilarious it's just when it
comes to very very long going Shawn in
series I tend to drop it for an
extremely long time and come back for a
couple episodes but for some reason I
still say oh that's a great anime
they're like oh man did you see the last
episode dude I haven't watch in so long
actually have you watched Fairy Tail I
did and personally not really too much
of my cup of tea
dammit I know they're not fairy tale is
the Chernin equivalent of
guilty-pleasure anime no nobody nobody
understands me that's the problem nobody
understands me no I get it
that's not the problem that's the
beautiful thing that's the big thing
Yoga ministry by the way it says any new
yokai anime because we all need more
essica anime everybody so are any are
any coming our way
I think no I don't know of any but I
don't think we talked about getting time
long enough because you don't seem like
you have the thirst to watch it yet with
get them I haven't seen it and I mean we
keep on but I just I just saw a comment
then I kind of went there is one thing
coming out next year that next year next
season that says here I didn't know it's
already that time nekopara yeah I know
like participate in their kicks sorry
cuz I totally did no I didn't play the
middle part of this game though I did
both of him I loved it it was so good
I'm looking forward to this looking
forward of the anime if it's an OVA now
and also there's Oso Matsu Suns second
season yeah
I really like this series I'm looking
out for the I wanna see next season
that's the mahou tsukai no Yami the
magician's bride dies away and where's
that my Haute's que no yoni that's
coming out next season
yeah yeah yes all I did watch the three
mm yes and I I loved it it was so
freakin good
I'm looking forward to this one oh so
much yeah are you sure it's not winter
season it's coming we always worked as a
pre meet to it so yeah alright and what
was that other one and then there's new
yashiki Azure dyes are I apparently the
manga had terrible reviews how follows
from a light novel it's from a visual
novel reviews I didn't read it
um do you know when violet ever garden
is playing that's next year January yep
winter season I definitely want to see
that yes following me that like pretty
freaking awesome apparently there's
something that happened at our ax I
think they had a premiere of it or the
first episode they got to see the first
episode where is no one else did yeah
yeah dude no I got invited to that stuff
too and I was like I can't because my
schedule topple over but it looks so
beautiful dude yeah I can't wait I can't
wait I was also another thing I got
invited to that I really wanted to see
but I can't because I'll be uh I'll be
out next week um was in Australia with
the koalas yeah I have to say I have to
see a well let me let me reword that I
said that I got invited to go see no
game no life zero for this weekend but a
lot of disorganization basically and I'm
super pissed because I love that series
yeah we know I wasn't a fan of no game
no life so we can argue that another day
Yawk you have a question for you or I
haven't answered I are you a true Sao
fan please leave please
this happen this is what I wanna know
because I don't know why week it's hard
to have guests with recon talk about the
morbidity of life and randomly Sao is
gonna pop up I am AI am a fan up until
like the sixth or seventh episode yeah
disappointed in you I
I'm not why we can't have nice things
but no yeah everyone everyone agrees
like Sao cool premise starts off well
but then you have all these characters
who don't develop they're just kind of
your token seasonal same thing as misty
said you can't explain this to recon
because Kirito is his waifu and it just
it's just it's what I didn't say is my
waifu i said he is my favorite character
yeah sure let's let's not do this again
doesn't mean waifu well this can't be a
weekly debate actually i get out of here
now to go try and set up for my next
thing so thank you so much for joining
us
no no worries no thank you
yeah I enjoyed our little collaboration
yeah no worries
yeah you guys just feel free to hit me
up on this card or whatever yeah yeah
cool talk Knox in private how you almost
gave me a heart attack
today that's cool everybody that was
awesome ah
vanishing line looks like another cool
item I was just looking at that anyone
else noticed this vanishing line it
looks like monster type anime at least
from the pole star it says you know
bratwurst city an only that threatens to
shake its world begins to move within it
a man named sword is the first to hear
the first series of the love original
anime names and throws himself into a
shadow
or in order to expose it his only clue
is the keyword El Dorado or the City of
Gold in Spanish he meets Sofia woman
searching for her missing older brother
who has only left her with the same
words El Dorado
I don't know what you're eating but it
sounds pretty crazy with sword having
also lost his younger sister in the past
both are drawn together by the by the
words and work together to find out its
meaning like I'm so interested in this
right now what animes are you reading
vanishing wine October 7th is when it
premieres foolish title of the series
yeah yeah it's on that minam a list
that's Ryan can you read that Japanese
one please it's not even that's the name
it's from mapa
I don't know whenever I think of El
Dorado elder what the hell whenever I
think of El Dorado the City of Gold I
think of that the Disney movie yeah yeah
and it's based at Disney movies based on
a real myth well obviously when the
conquistadores the spanish colonialist
came into america south america they
noticed that a lot of the native
population they had a lot of gold and
then this myth sprung up there was a
whole city made entirely of gold that
they were trying to find out actual real
life expeditions trying to find it they
never did but like yeah it's like a real
myth thing yeah it's cool garrow
vanishing line so if you look for that
week on your problem finding all right I
really do love original enemy because
you don't you don't know what's gonna
have you don't know what's what to
expect it's not expect either yeah this
is what I like because it's it's brand
new so people would want to watch it to
see what what it's all about it's not
following a manga it's not following
anything it's brand new that's what I
love about I think my favorite original
anime that's not based on anything it's
probably 91 days yeah I love that show
it's so good but aside from that I can't
think of anyone that I like I mean
recreate errs did I'll pardon me I don't
I don't wanna approach
my favorite classic knock star anyone's
personal space here but it is really not
that awesome it is men actually speaking
of free creators it's ending yeah I know
it's the final event what happened
occasionally at the end of seasons it
works like that
recon I'm not caught up I kind of fell
off as I got still 12 or something so
don't it didn't grip me in a way where I
want to keep watching it I don't know
but like I don't eat it I don't hate it
I think it's you guys are missing out
well every character is so
two-dimensional I would put it as like a
okay animate right now at best yeah you
guys are missing out the insane
character development that comes in you
guys are missing out you think yo yo
just wait 20 weeks
I'm this completely irrelevant but
Jonathan Essex just mentioned killa kill
as an original [ __ ] brawl made a film
I saw edgy bros video I didn't see it
yet what did be saved not said nothing
of substance like a lot of his videos so
yes nope
he says a lot of things that he likes
about it and if you try to repeat it
afterwards you will not find eight
minutes you'll be able to put together a
sentence of how it connects everything
it tries to do really well and he was
really good at pointing out all the good
points in fact he pointed out things
that he called good points that weren't
even good points and even you know he
made believe that it's an amazing show
because that's what he likes to do and
talked for eight minutes about something
even if it's not particularly special
he didn't mention Russo or a more proper
once he did not mention Russo or a more
proper ones how can you forget about
probably the best anime coming out Pingo
in the city
come on yeah you sent me that come on
Pingu in the city that's the best anime
oh well the OVA is I'm looking forward
to our Gundam origin Tenchi Muyo
we okie for season oh there's one of had
you Material Girl
and Terry engineer all I just hope it's
not no we're focusing only on that bad
guy that would be imagined as far as
movies though a fate/stay night heavens
feel yeah that's gonna be hiked threes
also getting an iMovie yeah no one cares
about that by the way yeah and we're
getting a Godzilla only so many people
are hyped up you come when I'm talking
to you you're not in the comments in my
wat who tsukino Cooney and no I'm not
I've actually never heard of this anime
unfortunately what else oh so much I
think the city
mentioned next season you haven't
watched it because it's not airing are
you guys just are you just talking to my
face
cold yeah the compilation movie first
movie comes out in October yeah equal
when no idea what we don't know however
we do know that the first movie comes
out in October so that's technically
part of the fall animes season but it's
gonna be a theatrical release so that's
like do you want to stream it and we all
watch it together with the people good
luck streaming it legally yeah it's hard
to stream legally that's why we have to
do it we've got dates date rough date
should we say of the free movies because
the first movie comes out the 21st of
October then the second movie is in
February of 2018 and then the next movie
after that is in the May of 2018
yeah but it's just that actual like they
states that they haven't given you yeah
that's true and but I'm looking forward
to this first movie I want to see you
know what is it gonna look like what are
they gonna change up and are they gonna
give us some news at the end of it like
you know how they did with the SAO movie
whatever it's called total news
the end of the third movie probably and
as far as me personally I am gonna wait
until you watch the movie and then ask
you what the differences are and if I
should watch it yeah it's worth because
they're supposed to have new scenes and
stuff new dubbing so we'll see you there
stuff that's actually different or if
it's just like Oh give us your money
yeah I want to see what the extra
dialogue could be that's gonna like lead
to or help Lincoln more the third season
have you guys watched dance with the
devils know most edgy anime somehow slip
under the radar well clearly not you
need to broaden your horizons it works
I recommend you guys to watch dance with
the Devils it's a reverse harem it's
probably one of the best reverse herons
so yeah definitely get to it if you
haven't if it's not your type then don't
why would I want to reverse her like I
it's rate six point six on my anime list
that's not that good yes but I will
never take a recommendation from you
alone without anything else backing I've
even watched one of the lowest rated
series like series are actually good but
I don't know why people rated it bad I
liked it
no but that's it that's the thing you
liked it but like no one else in the
world so exactly as I said before
anything I recommend you guys who's
gonna [ __ ] stay away from it yes your
micrometer man I need you everyone here
is crucial if either crap to get thrown
at mangas I go to Seoul he could throw
crap at any manga that I bet you know
that exists and finally did you talk to
someone who has similar tastes in me
I'll talk to Anna Mac with this I with
you know there are exceptions of course
and if I need to know what not to watch
I will ask you great movie that came out
a while ago in a blu-ray DVD release on
the 25th of October and it's called
genocidal organ that
it's really good I want to check that
out there it's one of the free movies
that were done by Project Ito because
basically this guy he won't novels in it
but he died during light in his fourth
one and I guess they're so good that
they decided to do like a free movie
project and turn his books into movies
there was the first one was Empire of
corpses yes kind of it's kind of loosely
based on the story of Frankenstein then
there's this one genocide organ which is
more of like a kind of army warm terror
kind of thing going on and then there's
another one called harmony which is
another kind of like futuristic
cyberpunk ish kind of feel with a lot of
like androids and things like that in in
the future and how people are like
wouldn't talk to them and things are not
that actually sounds quite cool to me I
guess Gintama guys you don't realize
we're talking one of the five greatest
Shonen of all time and this is an
undisputed you know a statistic I
already heard that you just made that
other it's an undisputed statistic
undisputed statistic the nut the nextel
meter is never wrong
the not-so meter is always wrong well
coming from you that's a compliment
no the check out kiseki no Kuni coming
out in the fall so I will definitely
give that a shot also look I'm seeing
here an anime called sorry eddo Sumi
beat oh wow to you to order which is
it's not an easy guy but it takes place
in an alternate world and it looks like
it involves war and alchemy because it
has spells spell formulas which have a
chemical reaction augmented with special
weapons to have like magic like effects
so it's kind of like an alchemist type
animal which sounds cool to me yeah
to me it looks like the cliche action
fantasy until I see actual substance I'm
not gonna get impressed by these anymore
daya horizon looks like it might be
interesting it's a fantasy
square enix this what by spraying yeah
it's a game company yeah we know if you
haven't played the game damn use a game
yeah which one yeah I know played games
every single one to play every single
one I'm looking forward to the horizon
to be on the cover of reminds me of
Heights against the Milgram car well you
can't judge a book by it's cover crap
wait to be I like Renoir there was no
problems for me to it I like that
except there was no story line that
actually progressed okay that's Unix
that's you there's a romance series that
I'm interested in but I'm gonna need
animal to pronounce what is it called
it's there in the in the chat no it's
gone now you got rid of it it's gone
just not what does the cover look like
the cover look like it's omiai Ida WA or
she ago soy yo Kim na mondo mondo ji
Moondoggie
oh god oh whoa we thought oh sweet
points who the hell are you man oh are
you talking about the anime short no
it's a series
this is series yeah
sir was a the to our female teacher and
her student but they are engaged holy
[ __ ] yeah it sounds interesting
HG Joe okay teacher and student
relationship I've seen before where is
the other way around where the teacher
was married to his student but they are
keeping it under wraps
yeah I mean I've seen I've seen like
anime like that so this one it's like
you know person do not do this in real
life kids
yeah it's very illegal good
yeah do not do this in real life fine
anime it's okay I'm like expecting
they're not illegal if the student is
over 18 but it's still like you would
get fired and stuff for your job because
you're not supposed to be seducing your
students of course but of course
soul maka isn't interested in this no
I'm not but the problem with this is
guys is that anime with only one love
interest this is why harems are needed
and I'm disappointed no one love
interest is good I prefer a whole bunch
of love interests well the problem is
usually with that no one gets bloody
chosen there are so did you watch my top
tens I made about number one I remember
yes I I did I did three parts of that
era many were main character and my main
character chooses a girl there are a
seers like that yeah a series that about
cuz look whenever I choose a girl but
that people be like oh you chose the
wrong girl and it will be a plain and
obvious choice who he will end up with
and that's what will happen and will be
boring and there will be other
characters that are better than the main
love interest because that's how it
usually goes or it's not obvious in the
beginning and those never get anywhere
or have you have you guys watched the
series maji de watashi the samurai one
with
oh yeah yeah the guy at the end the guy
chooses a hermit crab which pissed me
off by the way in the chat guys let us
know if there's any anime that you want
us to talk about that we haven't talked
about yeah that's coming out in fall
2017 but in the meantime in the meantime
I think that this season is going to be
like last season
kind of yeah nothing like whoa you know
there has been a bit of a letdown as far
as original anime yeah definitely equals
a lot of different sequels but nothing
original that really stood out I mean I
guess in the beginning Mia Tonya the
evil witch was not bad again it's one of
those where it's like oh it's something
to watch but it's not like oh this is
amazing
there was no mind-blowing show this I
mean every year like as far as I could
remember had at least one like last year
you know last year there was um my hero
academia started Reesie row
I like bungo Street dogs better than
anything going on now or at least that
went on this whole year
mob psycho 100 like good stuff last year
like when you when you say original
anime you mean something like with its
own unique style I mean not a sequel
like this year we had attack on Titan
season two we had Kona super season 2 we
had my hair academia's season - we're
having shokugeki no souma season 3 those
are the memorable titles aside from that
there was saga of Tanya the evil and
there was dragon made okay although I
think my favorites one of my favorite
anime this year that wasn't a sequel was
Gabriel drop out I don't know if any you
watched it yeah I liked it it was good I
loved that show that was the second
season yeah there was it needs a second
season I want to see my girls say Tanya
Guinea oh she was best girl he was best
girl oh my god I can't deal with you see
I told you we don't agree with [ __ ] no
but you both agreed that you liked the
series best girl for you nuts
gabber do do earlier of course
Gabrielle's coming out called King game
or Oh summer game yeah Chad wants to
talk about this and yeah it looks really
interesting like the description it
starts off like sounding just like a
slice of life and then there's like this
crazy twist so yeah so I'll take away
yeah I mean yeah it sounds interesting
the only the only thing I worry about it
as an anime adaption is that it's called
that animation because I've noticed
every anime that comes out and it's
called the animation is up really bad
and as far as hentai and speaking of
hentai it's made by Studio seven do any
of you know what seven makes that's
right it makes a hell of a lot of hentai
it does not make anime it made okusama
and aside from that it made you know
Ron's I'm reading through it now Ron's
shikoku no chaga and didn't want Baku
Hani you know all these Opaka won the
motorcycle work no but no not that at
all but a ton of a ton of hentai it's
all that guy oh my god
I'm looking in this I'm looking at the
pictures for awesome on game and there's
a lot of waifu material here guys i
don't know the art style seems
interesting and also it's interesting
again it's based off a novel those can
either go really well or really poorly
that's interesting they must not yeah
it's a hentai studio it's like edge if
they know how to do this I don't know I
don't know if they're gonna know how to
do this series it's probably gonna suck
most likely lune I wanted to talk about
dynamic cord I haven't heard of that
by the way yeah here at the bottom it's
a music anime so I'm probably not gonna
watch it unless there is not enough yaoi
anime and you know I not share your
concern I have no interest in yaoi or
urea anime but to each his own you guys
watched wake up girls so actually
speaking of yaoi and Yuri anime and your
distaste for it I think I understand why
and it may have to do with your real
life coming up yes yeah yeah it's
because like I like to relate to like
protagonists that all the chicks are
into cuz I'm like yeah that's real life
for me guys yeah he's like oh cool is
like the the yaoi fan art that's been
done with him and no no no there's no
such thing there's no such thing please
do not that's got any news right now
soul do not engage in unacceptable
behavior on earth
we're still waiting for the rant cafe
dojin lalala that's what does anyone
mentions like genderbent communist like
if you want that nuts you have to invite
in more females
yessir guys guys what about this quinoa
Mackey was Aki the first female on the
no no no without Britain before and we
had rose we had this art yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah we we had some more but
um the point is guys the yaki no no
Tommy that's quino's journey I talked
about that already recon that's the one
I haven't seen it's a remake or an older
anime that I really enjoyed oh I don't
have to watch it to watch this one right
no okay
although and you know the studio it's
making its large studio they're
legendary for the you know basically
high schools that are screwed up and end
up killing people I think that I yes an
assassination classroom love them
classroom is just good good stuff they
did on the robot they did classroom the
elite they did Mouse orzo is okay the
magical girl they did faith carnival
phantasm holy crap they did this monster
Misumi OBJ's as well they did Cousineau
honk i and gakkou gurashi you didn't
like whoo zero hunger
did you not like you guys talking about
it because I did not did not watch it
I love God Cucaracha yahoo is such a
good series zombie high school that's
good why I like the first episode of
gakkou gurashi Gilgamesh asks if I
watched a query on I'm hurt I'm keep
hearing this name now I think glass
reflections or whatever but I haven't
should I be it's quite good
you watch it I thought is more don't
watch it
damn it went access mad than I usually I
usually go check out the first episode
sleeves szymek some mecha anime my taste
whenever I say men I think that I shared
you know me and anime ik on a mech level
we agree yeah cuz you you like like some
of your favorite animes also my favorite
animes like Code Geass right so like we
have to have to I have to take your
opinion the knuckle meter is almost
always right killer killed but otherwise
it's pretty good look I don't want you
to think that I hate killa kill I just
hate that you love it so much
no it's true it's kind of like with with
me and like sort out on mine I don't
hate it
well then recon keeps praising it so
much i sonic man like no reality over
hate it like I always say sir I want a
[ __ ] masterpiece you don't mess with
it why this place can't say it's good
either
[Music]
alright guys I think we've had a good
one here today I'm gonna have to have a
private talk with Knox taco after this
but no this is definitely a cool cool
rent cafe I hope you guys got some ideas
about what's plugins gonna be coming out
this upcoming season like I said I don't
see anything that's gonna be super
impressive but I will be open-minded
hopefully we there will be something
interesting we do have some sequels like
food Wars March comes in like a line we
have Emoto or merch on right so Gintama
so we have a few sequels that are well
known animal we have a few originals we
have a few brand-new animes so it backed
according to statistics Gintama is one
of the top five hunters PETA best
shonan's what's the knocks you anywho
guys thank you for joining us as always
everyone in the chat knocks who are you
what do you do tell the people by the
way leave a like if you enjoy Ryan cafes
and you want us to keep going
you just got two dislikes bro
those dislikes were here for a while man
it wasn't me by the way
no I'm sure it wasn't as soon as I'm
like SEO is not that good because it's
just like [ __ ] you that's how edgy he is
he's like an edge Lord wasn't me no I
recon is is is like a cool edge Lorna
he's no edge Lord for like highschool
DxD I can deal with that I don't like
people are like pull that a call like
edge Lauren's [ __ ] like that
like this I can I can bear his hei
Ramesh Lord edge lordship we've known
each other for how long a year almost
yeah probably I don't even know man on
YouTube everything it feels like a
hundred years but it's like two weeks oh
yeah knocks who are you what do you get
though hi I'm nuts Taku I have a channel
on the YouTube and I do anime related
content
I actually apparently have decent
contacts right Mac yes apparently you do
sir
and want dirt a lot of people a lot of
leverage yeah you never know but um you
don't know what I have on you but so I
for the most part I used to make mostly
sarcastic stuff and I'm leaning towards
analysis and decoding anime and that's
where my channel is gonna be heading for
a little while but you're casting stuff
is saying never fear you've got some
cool interesting stuff out right now and
death no you got some cool interesting
stuff out on my ear academia recent
stuff so yeah definitely check out his
channel link in the description oh and
the next Death Note movie I'm gonna send
it to you unlisted first oh cool movie
before we go it's gonna be lit by the
way guys
knocks luck was latest video I said
awesome job man this was great and he
thought that I was being like ironic or
something he's like bro like did you
really like him like you didn't like
yeah man I really enjoyed it like he
just didn't expect me to be so positive
I guess no no no your occasionally
positive but you wrote good video period
and I'm like no it was it I was like
awesome job or something in said generic
a good video it had a period well I use
periods when I talk I like Brian don't
use periods ever not not the case not
the case oh yeah knocks link in the
description the guy who has connections
in the anime community no one knows how
he comes out of the blue and he pulls it
through then we have anime recon your
boy can't go last
there sa Oh lover last Co watcher
self-proclaimed harem King despite bro
just [ __ ] you can I go last or do I have
to go right now you have to go right now
alright what up it's your boy recon and
I do the Recon Oh Peter we know that's
that's what everyone calls me because
that's what I'm known but anyways I do
them top 10 anime lists and I do with
them reactions but um I'm starting to
think that mostly I'm gonna be
towards doing more toptenz than
reactions because you know that has
really affected my channel I decided to
show my face for the first time and I
took everyone's advice and so far so
good everything's going very well yeah
and I really like I look at your recent
videos where you show your face you talk
a bit about and why you voted why you
chose the number one position and
obviously I think that's very cool good
work
yeah showing a little bit of my
personality which surprised a lot of
people a lot of my fans have been liking
it so far so appreciated yeah good
advice comes from good sources very
often you can trust it yeah your channel
is growing well recon you're getting
help from the best and that's all in the
community for the help people thank you
for the help especially Lux and soul
annum accurate you're not really helpful
yeah I like I'm more like no but I'm
like the best guy because I'm like you
have to fly you know you have to fly on
your own you have to pull yourself up by
your own bootstraps but I'm here for you
I'm like you know I'm that distance
sensei like I'm the guy that you have to
he's the dad that teaches his kids had a
swim by throwing him at the deep end no
you said misty was my dad no yeah misty
is your father but I'm your son say like
I'm like the guy you know that you move
up towards like to get in help from me
you have to go through you don't my you
know my captains and then you come to me
and then I show you the truth and then
you're not ready for it who are your
captains Knox soul then what am i you
are your there's a lovely little weed
you're just walking through the the
chambers of Shaolin you know all right
and you destroyed him dude that's recon
link in the description makes quality
list list videos does some reactions to
which are entertaining in their own
right so yeah check out watch them
though don't watch the swaps thank God
thank you time speed button best
promotion for your own channel to give
and of course we got soul maka who is
going to be launching his channel
sometime soon he's got an intro for it
now you've been working on the videos
you said you're gonna try to get it out
last week but you didn't am i correct
yes that's this right yeah I'm still
working on the coin no katachi
manga/anime review just being mad busy
at the moment
and I really need to catch up on some
hentai work so yeah it's a bit delayed
but it is coming and once that comes
others will come anti work it's coming
yes yes well at least my work someone
else might we have to have priorities
guys that we know on hentai is the
priority and then everything else comes
after that well thank you soul when soul
does get his channel of course we will
have links in the description for him as
well and we had another person join us
at this Red Cafe our young youtuber
known as Aki dearest I didn't have her
link in description because I was
surprised by it but of course Aki beerus
has her own channel check it out i'm
sure you already have but if you haven't
check it out and yeah thank you everyone
for joining us really interesting one
this week i am i didn't fangirl down
much so it was okay that was quick
hearing it and we can't move themselves
screaming yes silence screaming who's
coming the next rank of a that is the
question will it be nigahiga who's come
we don't know he's gonna bring joy the
enemy man believe it or not mega Giga
has voiced for me in a video no yes oh
you go I've made an old Naruto abridged
if you want to go check it out that's
great
going knocks what line knocks your ear
your Big Town bro I like you knocks get
the Joey the anime man to come in the
stream if you talk to him that is get
join the enemy man to do a live reaction
with recon to sitting side by side and
laugh okay you get Noble in noble will
probably be like he probably enjoys
sword oh my but like I know
does not so now I give it four minutes
not even like two and a half minutes
before they started slapping each other
if Johnson the moment the moment Joey
comes to the stream I am bringing up
Yuri ah nice cuz I need someone that
hates it on my side I don't think he
wants to be talking about that [ __ ]
anymore to be honest watched it though
but I'm on your side in the sense that
I'm not interested in it alright but
I'll take that sorry
you get double for anime love you yes
yeah fun time still fun times definitely
on my cafe it's been a great journey for
number episode 43 now and you know
having really awesome guests including
that you guys to guess here and everyone
in the chat and just always fun to hang
out with the crew with the chod people
oh by the way if you want to continue
the discussion on our discord server
link in the description NOx is their
soul is their recon is their we got all
day weren't there at first but we made
all of them join the discord because we
are not a cult
we just make it do stuff yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah and in about now it's time I'll
probably be doing a voice chat session
you know the discord server as well
where we just like you know talk about
everything
manga anime games you know all sorts
eighty-eight youtubers will have nice
I'll try to pop in as well I have some
birthday event to attend later but I
will definitely try to pop in as well
always find the voice chat we've 10
[ __ ] that's right well I love the
emphasis you put on done [ __ ] I love it
but yeah thank you guys so much for
watching for joining us for hanging it
out as always until next time see us
space cowboys we come back